merry perhelion
everyone on this day Earth in its orbit
around the sun the sun is closer than it
is at any other day of the year yes it
happens in
January
perihelion I celebrate that as do all of
my
colleagues and uh oh you thinking well
how come in the northern hemisphere it's
cold well then obviously the distance
from the Sun has nothing to do with your
climate that has to do with the tip of
our axis are we tipped towards the Sun
or away from it making the sun's Rays
more direct if you're tipped towards it
but uh otherwise yeah I'm loving it and
the Sun is a little bigger in the sky
and uh this Earth is moving faster in
its orbit now than at any other time
this this is the astrodynamics of the
solar system